o
eu confesso que eu sempre quis usar esse
microfone estilo madonna mas essa
primeira oportunidade que estou tendo no
segmento bem como funciona
obrigado bom meu nome é thiago eu
trabalho departamento de design da
universidade
eu trabalho com avaliações econômicas de
interface usabilidade
mas podem ficar tranquilos que não é
nada disso que eu vou falar que agora
vai ser algo um pouco mais divertido
podem ficar calmos
o que eu quero falar com vocês na
verdade a minha primeira aventura no
campo das artes é a minha primeira
experiência nesse sentido é um trajeto
um pouco mais pessoal e quando eu eu me
deparei com esse desafio de tentar
propor uma poética de ressignificar a
algo a primeira questão que me ocorreu
foi o que eu gostaria de expressar o que
eu gostaria de falar com as pessoas
sobre o que gostaria de discutir e aí
talvez fortemente influenciado pelo
nascimento do meu do meu pequeno filho
no meu correu outra coisa que não falar
um pouco sobre a beleza que eu vejo ea
sofisticação que eu vejo no processo de
vida
então o que eu tentei fazer foi criar
uma poética que falasse um pouco da
maneira como eu vejo a vida bom
resumindo um pouco a história adiantando
um pouco a conversa eu criei um sistema
de vida artificial tá que ele cria essas
configurações orgânicas a partir de
objetos geométricos mais ou menos como a
gente tem aqui e parece um fungo uma
árvore né mas o que interessa mais não é
o arranjo em si é a maneira como ele é
construído e aí o que ele significa
antes de falar um pouco mais sobre esse
sistema eu queria propor um olhar pra
essa conversa nossa peça fala eu queria
que vocês é é pensassem que a gente não
precisa sempre fica preso aos campos
disciplinares da maneira como a gente
encontra né
eu tinha o interesse de falar sobre
essas questões que são questões de
biologia mas eu sou designer e eu queria
fazer isso propondo é por meio de
processos computacionais e eu propus
isso no campo das artes então eu acho
que que é possível que a gente consiga
navegar por esses campos disciplinares
guiados pela nossa vontade de
transformar o mundo pelos nossos sonhos
a então esse é o primeiro olhar que eu
proponho pra essa conversa
voltando para a poética o meu objetivo
então era de criar essa poética
né que fosse é concebida exclusivamente
por processos computacionais
eu não queria desenhar é uma imagem que
fosse importada e eu queria que ela
representasse a lógica da de manutenção
e desenvolvimento da vida
bom pra entender um pouquinho a vida eu
busquei no show liga esse show liga
mesmo né da física quântica mas não
entende nada da física quântica então
busquei um outro livro dele que fala
sobre a vida ele e lhe propõe a vida
como um grande desequilíbrio energético
existe uma tendência de transformação da
energia e matéria no universo é essa
tendência à acomodação existe e essas
transformações fazem com que essa
energia se torne cada vez um sistema
menos reversível que é o que a gente
chama de entropia toque a vida ela surge
a partir de uma estrutura que foge um
pouco essa lógica né
ela surge de uma estrutura que pra
existir ela precisa consumir parte da
organização desse universo
a gente precisa consumir organização em
forma de energia potencial como raio do
sol a respiração os alimentos ea gente
precisa desfazer essa organização ea
partir dessa desorganização desfeita a
gente consegue é viver e devolver para o
mundo um pouco de caos no formato de de
calor por exemplo tá
a partir desse processo a gente é capaz
de construir nosso próprio corpo é capaz
de conseguir energia para se locomover
fazer as nossas acções num processo que
a gente chama de autopoiese ea partir de
interações de unidades alto poéticas
menores que a gente tem a emergência de
estruturas maiores estruturas que não
foram previstas pelas unidades menores
mas que vão surgindo ao longo do tempo
por meio de um processo de seleção
natural
essa seleção ocorre em pequenos passos
a gente não tem uma uma estrutura
complexa suficiente que seja capaz de
surgir um passo único a não ser que seja
feita né pelos humanos
mas naturalmente ela surge em pequenos
passos graduais e a gente queria que a
gente chama de estruturas complexas né
como a gente mesmo no campo da arte
computacional evolutiva onde o inseriu
é essa complexidade foi chamado de
complexidade efetiva enquanto a de
computacional evolutiva foi proposto que
essa lógica esse tipo de complexidade
deveria ser a meta de representação dos
artistas e essa é esse tipo de
complexidade ele não é uma nação de
complexidade como a gente tem outras
áreas como um excesso de variáveis ou de
relação entre as variáveis do sistema
ela na verdade é composta por pitadas de
organização e desorganização
mas ela surge uma proficiência uma
funcionalidade e no campo das artes
deveria significar uma expressão
artística do do artista
vendo a cara de vocês né eu imagino que
estão pensando agora eu queria que vocês
colocassem no meu lugar que já tinha
topado desafio de fazer a proposta
prática sobre esse tema agora tinha que
criar um sistema que representasse tudo
de alguma forma
bom é pra tentar representar esse
sistema sem saber programar mas que
fosse um sistema computacional
eu acabei por tentativa e erro num
processo que foi um pouquinho longo é
criar é um sistema adaptativo
multiagentes ele é um sistema complexo
atrativo que funciona por meio de
algoritmos genéticos e por inteligência
artificial enxame
eu também não sou dessa área é pra
representar porque eu queria representar
visualmente talvez influenciado por
essas unidades ao topo e éticas eu
tentei trabalhar com o universo
microscópico
eu tentei representar células do que
seriam as imagens não é essas células
são fundamentos de linguagem são linhas
pontos cores formas que brigam e
competem para tentar compor uma imagem
que a gente vê a olho nu foi essa
analogia que eu usei
então a minha criatura artificial ela é
composta por um risco um rabisco no qual
são colocadas algumas formas geométricas
tem uma cor de preenchimento uma cor de
de contorno elas morrem e possui também
movimentos quando estão vivas
elas emitem sons elas são capazes de
interagir umas com as outras
elas caçam as outras entidades mais
fracas elas fogem das mais fortes elas
criam grupos colaborativo elas criam
grupos de submissão elas são capazes de
eu vou lá entrar no cio a casa lá
e indiretamente a gente tem aqui uma
cena de sexo explícito a gente tem
vários agentes e produzindo tá
eles são capazes de gerar um ser novo e
esse ser gerado ele possui
características mescladas dos pais por
meio de recombinação de dna
eles brigam também eles conseguem se
alimentar de energia da casa dos seus
inimigos mortos
tá bom é quando eu pego um sistema desse
e preenche as variáveis de dna de
maneira randômica nevo gerando
randomicamente todas essas propriedades
a gente tem uma composição que funciona
mais ou menos do jeito que a gente está
vendo aqui é mais ou menos como fica a
parede da minha casa quando aquela minha
inspiração lá pega canetinha e começa a
desenhar livremente né
a gente tem uma situação que na verdade
na verdade é muito previsível né é uma
situação que a gente tem uma heterogênea
idade homogêneo porque é ela é
previsível de acordo com a lei dos
grandes números a gente sempre vai ter
uma distribuição meio atrapalhada mas
quando o sistema começa a funcionar e
essas entidades começam a interagir
a gente tem é por meio dessas regras de
comportamento uma situação diferente
aqui eu tenho uma versão bastante
acelerado do sistema tais que vocês
estão vendo são gerações e gerações de
criaturas que morrem nascem a todo
momento e que começam a transformar a
composição visual já então as
transformações de cores e formas que
vocês vêem na verdade são transformações
genéticas são outras criaturas que já
nasceram tá isso aqui são a gente com
acompanha cerca de 50 gerações mais ou
menos nesse pequeno espaço de tempo tá
ea partir desse processo é são possíveis
arranjos como esse aqui tá que surgem
com o passar do tempo esse aqui é esse
aqui né
o que é interessante com relação a esses
arranjos é na verdade uma tentativa de
compreensão do significado dessas cores
e formas distribuídas
elas representam graus de parentesco
elas representam uma variação do tipo de
de variabilidade genética que a
população tem e elas elas se comportam
de maneira diferente em termos visuais
do que aquele primeiro modelo randômico
que a gente tem que é muito comum com
processos aleatórios gerado pelo
computador
é essa situação do lado de cá ela tende
ela sugere um pouco mais a complexidade
efetiva e uma intencionalidade no
sentido de criação
no entanto não foi concebida ela se auto
arranjou dessa maneira na com relação
aos sons
a gente tem também uma situação de som
randômico esse é o tipo de som com o
ambiente randômico produz um som
igualmente econômico com novos
instrumentos surgindo mas quando esse
sistema começa a evoluir uma nova
situação de som também ocorre a gente
tem aqui fica o baixinho mas a gente tem
uma espécie de jazz evolutivo não é que
surgiu desses agentes como a mesma
afinidade de instrumentos e afinidade de
tempos mais ou menos o que acontece um
visualmente bom com relação à pesquisa
que foi feita nessa essa política foi
feita num contexto de uma pesquisa
deu tudo certo não conseguir falar um
pouquinho sobre essa questão da
complexidade os conceitos relacionados
tem apenas uma onde está que eu gostaria
de fazer é que por meio de uma de uma
poética no campo das artes foi possível
antecipar uma questão científica foi
possível promover uma publicação falando
da possibilidade de manutenção da
variabilidade genética de uma população
por meio de recombinação de dna e essa
publicação antecedeu uma outra de uma
parceria de três universidades
americanas que fazem a mesma coisa mas
não uma demonstração de um modelo
matemático então às vezes nem mesmo essa
fronteira entre arte e ciência que a
gente encontra por aí dentro do ambiente
acadêmico fora deles não são tão rígidas
como a gente às vezes imagina não é como
a gente encontre voltando pra a questão
da poética o que eu gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês não é nenhuma
dessas questões de pesquisa
mas é na verdade é um pouco da das
discussões das reflexões que surgiram na
pesquisa a partir do contato das pessoas
com o sistema interativo
nas mostras de arte ou nas instalações
que foram feitas a primeira delas são só
duas no projeto é a primeira delas é
sobre uma sensibilização e uma reflexão
que foi feita com relação ao impacto das
nossas ações e ambientes de de em
sistemas complexos né
então as pessoas começaram a perceber
que o tipo de ação que a gente promove
pode ser colaborativo
realmente destrutivo nesse tipo de
sistema quando a gente consegue ampliar
um pouquinho a escala de tempo de
observação do sistema
então as pessoas começaram a perceber
isso na interação com esse sistema e
depois começaram a transpor um pouco
dessa lógica o jeito que a gente se
comporta ocupando as cidades no trânsito
né
a questão do trânsito também é muito
importante foi fez surgiu bastante
quando a gente discutir essas questões
com o meio ambiente está como um todo
então a primeira questão que eu acho que
foi interessante pra mim que que me fez
sentir satisfeito com essa
ressignificação desse objeto sobre a
vida eo nosso papel na vida foi esse o
nosso papel com relação aos sistemas em
que a gente atua mas também foi proposta
uma outra noção de vida um pouco
diferente da que eu estava estudando mas
continuando essa linha de raciocínio foi
proposta uma percepção da vida como um
processo que não é mais um processo
individual eles abandonaram a noção de
vida enquanto propriedade individual foi
proposta uma noção de vida enquanto
propriedade coletiva né
a vida é a mesma vida todos temos um
ancestral comum então essa vida enquanto
entidade ela surge lá no meio de uma
caverna no fundo do oceano de um de uma
lugar poroso cresceu nem virou é multi
células dominou os mares a superfície do
planeta e atualmente a gente está saindo
dessa superfície né então é essa vida
multicorpos é assim como um corpo tem
várias células
ela é uma entidade um pouco diferente da
maneira como a gente percebe a vida no
nosso dia a dia
ela é uma vida de corpo disperso ela é
uma vida que se a gente consegue
imaginar uma escala maior de tempo que a
escala no qual esse processo dá ela é
extremamente mutante extremamente
adaptada ela se transforma várias
situações né e ela não só se transforma
ela continua se expandindo e crescendo
nesse universo então os nossos corpos
morrem eles morrem mas a vida em si ela
continua existindo
ela não só continue existindo como ela
se expande mesmo estando naquele
universo com uma tendência absoluta
decaimento então é dentro dessa noção de
de vida enquanto o desequilíbrio
energético enquanto propriedade coletiva
ela é um modelo extremamente frágil né é
um modelo sofisticado
e é um modelo altamente improvável
porque ele mexe de uma série de
interações de outros elementos menores
tá que ocorre numa escala absurda de
tempo para as nossas escalas
perspectivas tá então apesar disso tudo
a gente faz parte desse processo a gente
está inserido nesse sistema independente
da nossa vontade querendo ou não
colaborando não tentando visualizar isso
não a gente faz parte desse sistema
independente das nossas intenções
por isso a sugestão que fica é nós damos
o nosso significado para a nossa própria
vida
somos nós que fazemos isso por meio das
nossas ações e esse é o pensamento que
eu queria compartilhar com vocês sobre a
poética obrigado